let's make way for Sam Miller enjoyed
the column the article is welcome to the
era of terrible horrible no good very
bad 30 homerun hitters all right you had
me at the the title there Sam welcome to
the program thanks for joining us all
right is this a good thing or bad thing
with what's happened with all these home
runs this year
you know it's what to say because the
fact is that baseball was already going
to this sort of slow and stagnant style
of play just because pitchers throw so
hard because there are so many good
pitchers that bull pens are sick with 99
mile an hour fastball throwers and teams
that are trying to win are simply going
to load up on pitchers who can get
strikeouts and pitchers are gonna try to
strike guys out and so baseball was
already getting sort of slow and
inactive and without the homeruns I
think we'd probably be in a place where
offense was so low that team would fall
behind 3 2 1 in the fifth inning and
there really would be no point in still
watching now that said I think that the
incentives have also caused a lot more
players to swing for the fences in a way
that a lot of people not just purist but
casual fans as well find a little bit
aesthetically boring and it is kind of
often sand the defensive sort of spurred
each other into this arms race of boom
or bust and I don't know that it's the
most exciting style of playing but I'm
very confident it's not the most
exciting cylla play that said homeruns
you know they're right now they're
keeping the game afloat a little bit and
in the examples that I cited with some
of these players they're keeping careers
going that might otherwise have been
endangered why the sudden burst rise in
homeruns
now I know we've heard a lot of reasons
if I said what's the number one overall
reason Sam why we've had you know this
explosion in homeruns well the number
one overall reason is most likely that
in the summer of 2015
around the all-star break something
changed in a manufacturer of baseballs
I'm not saying it was conspiracy I'm not
saying it was intentional but I believe
that
most likely the evidence suggests that
most likely teams got new baseballs
those baseball's had probably slightly
lower seams the courage the you know the
resistance of balls went down a little
bit and that small effect I had caused a
lot more home runs and I think players
are able to sense that home runs are a
little cheaper now and you've seen more
players go for home runs and you know
try to get more fly balls and maybe
swing a little bit more aggressively but
I think the primary cause is probably
there's no proof of this but there's
really good evidence strong evidence
that the baseball changed a little bit
but Sam can the manufacturer do
something without permission from Major
League Baseball well it's interesting
because the specifications that baseball
gives to manufacturers are sufficiently
broad that within those specifications
within those specifications you're
talking about baseball's that might
travel 20 or 30 extra feet depending on
which extreme of the specifications you
are in it's been the case Allen Nathan
is a physicist who has done a lot of
work on baseball in general and
baseball's specifically and he's shown
that within the same batch you can even
have two baseball's that might travel 15
feet differently based on small really
very small things I really don't think
that there's a conspiracy here I don't
think that this was intentional by the
manufacturer or baseball and again we're
talking about something that is so far
there's not completely convincing
evidence that this is even happening
baseball hasn't acknowledged that this
has happened but the answer to your
question is yes there without even
trying a very small change could could
cause relatively large differences in
the way the baseballs played
we're talking to Sam Miller national
baseball columnist feature writer for
ESPN former editor-in-chief of Baseball
Prospectus
I keep hearing launch angle here Sam is
if everybody decided they were going to
change their swing and the launch angle
would be different
how much do you credit
launch angle with these hitters for the
influx of hormones I think that for
individual players there are careers
that we have seen change along with the
trajectory of the baseball's that
they've been hitting so I think that
there's no doubt that like for instance
Josh Donaldson of the Toronto Blue Jays
was an early adopter of this launch
angle idea the idea that he should just
sell out and hit a lot more fly balls
and that does go counter to a lot of
hitting instructions that these guys are
raised on which is hit down on the ball
hit line drives and it makes sense that
some players have figured out that in
fact hitting fly balls is pretty good
because home runs count for more than
everything else so I'm not denying that
there's some of that going on but if you
look at the way that home runs started
coming really almost literally overnight
in July of 2015 I don't even know if I
need to say almost literally literally
overnight if you look week by week it's
like the line just spiked
it's hard to imagine that there was a
sudden league wide awakening to the idea
that home runs are good it's been
roughly a century that we've known home
runs are good you had the incident
yesterday at Yankee Stadium where the
little girl was hit by the foul ball
how does baseball react to this well you
know I I think that baseball has always
liked that this is a sport that is sort
of scary when you think about what's
going on this baseball is hard and it
goes fast and there are a lot of people
in danger on every pitch and we've been
lucky that there have not really been a
lot of tragedies or deaths in the sport
for a long time and so there hasn't been
a need or I guess baseball has it felt I
need to really take drastic steps to
protect the fans or for that matter the
pitchers or perhaps even the catchers
and what troubles me is that eventually
something really severely tragic is
going to happen and then they'll act and
it just feels like this is a situation
netting in front of some seats to me
doesn't seem like something that you
need to really fight that
hard against you know as my friend Harry
pallidus pointed out yesterday the most
expensive seats in the stadium are also
the ones behind netting right now which
suggests strongly that consumers get
used to it that it isn't a significant
construction in the game
I think there's been momentum toward
more netting obviously in the last few
years and I just really like to see
people fix problems before the terrible
terrible terrible thing happens and I
don't know if yesterday was a wake-up
call that was a really hard team to
watch you know and you know I got a lot
more attention than the average foul
ball but you know it's putting some
people in danger on almost every touch
Sam thank you enjoyed the column good
luck the rest of the season thanks for
joining us you're welcome that's Sam
Miller
he's with the mothership now feature
writer for them baseball columnist the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience